this quote really kills me my mother is
the only person left who knew me as a
kid so therefore there should be no
secrets between us I don't want any
secrets between us
yeah but don't you think a mother and
son should have some cider it's not so
much secrets this I don't think there's
to be anything left unsaid like for me
my dad died when I was 10
and I used to have this fantasy that he
had maybe written me a letter and the
letter would show up when I turned 18 or
when I turned 21 it would tell me all
the things I didn't know about him it
would tell me everything he wanted for
my life and of course there wasn't any
letter and I realized I didn't want the
same thing with my mom when so when
she's no longer here I didn't want there
to be all this stuff like who was this
person and so we set out to kind of
change the conversation between us you
and your mom email each other right yeah
that's the thing and that's what started
it that's how we honor 91st birthday we
started basically new we like
consciously started a new kind of
conversation and no embarrassment but
isn't it amazing your mother at 91 even
has email like my parents are they are
not even open she got an email at 90 and
I couldn't I couldn't do it because it
drove me nuts she didn't know it so I
got a friend of mine to do it as much
more patient event we sat there with her
and explained it explained it over and
over and over again she was open to it
oh and the total exchange her life see
your mother is a very unusual woman
number one she lived in unusual life
yeah but she's open to things yes no
believe me she's open to a lot of things
yeah and even like open about speaking
about her love life you know most people
are closed down yeah but what an
impressive list I mean your mother dated
Errol Flynn every flight when I was a
kid I'm a big actor I'd watch like an
Oldman Hood with Errol Flynn when I was
like 10 years old with my mom and I
turned her and said do you ever know
Errol Flynn and should be like oh yes is
it a mother's obligation to even though
she had slept with him isn't it her
obligation to not include you in that do
you think she was inappropriate with you
no she didn't she wouldn't go into gory
details and she does write about in the
book that Howard Hughes was the first
person who made her having an orgasm
without faking it I was that guy did you
ask her if how could because Howard
Hughes was an infamous sufferer of OCD
germs you know the hole right but this
was hot Howard Hughes
not crazy top of the desert but even
then apparently she was saying that he
would eat the same thing every meal
which frankly I do as well me too yeah
yeah yeah but I have a little that I see
a lot of that oh yeah I know for like
six months at a time eating the same
thing every day
me too and I wear the same thing every
day it's just less decisions who wants
to care and you become obsessive yes
yeah I I believe that's why Hillary
Clinton has switched to this sort of
outfit that she wears she doesn't want
to have to like a guy she doesn't want
to decide everywhere I've read that
President Obama does the same thing that
he has like a blue suit and a grey suit
and it's just too less decisions he has
to make every day absolutely but I mean
you know when you read the book you know
your mother at 28 dates Frank Sinatra
who's like it's like dating the Beatles
of that power I know yeah is it
nonchalant kind of explanations from
your mother or is it like a big deal
that she dated Frank I mean it's it
seems normal to her I mean she's like
Frank Sinatra came along he was playing
at the Copacabana in New York and he
contacted a friend and wanted to go out
with her and she left her husband
because that she was looking for a way
to get out of the marriage and she was
married to a guy who was she met him she
was 21 he was 63 Wow genius conductor
Leopold Stokowski Yeah right
she claims he didn't look 63 I'm like
mom he looks like 63 but what so yeah I
mean that she was 21 yeah I'm married a
63 year old and not like she was 21 and
very wealthy and married a 60 it wasn't
like she married him for love right your
mother was a wealthy woman didn't need
to marry 63 oh she is unbelievable this
woman she really is yeah why in the doc
you described in the book she describes
somebody who she was dating at 85 as the
Nijinsky of cunnilingus to look up
Nijinsky she's a ballet I got modern
dancer ballet dancer very limber I
assume you're saying there was some guy
who performed cunnilingus on your mother
when she was 85 and he was so good I
just thought it was funny I was like
geez mom I don't need to hear this she
said to you he was the Nijinsky
cunnilingus yet unbelievable my mother
my mother
but it's very great that you really know
you it's cool and that she knows me as
an adult you know and and and that we're
able to like basically kind of replay
all these things that happen between us
and see them from different perspectives
are you as open with her no I mean I'm
yeah I'm open with her but I like I'm
not going into details of like sacrifice
yeah